[Applause]
we've gotten big mix of everybody in the
club gay straight bi whatever and
everyone is welcome
the club has completely changed my life
BMW proudly supports the LGBTQ community
[Music]
[Music]
the challenges that the people were
facing in the 1990s were fairly standard
there was an automatic link between
being gay and being pedophile you
certainly couldn't be macho when I heard
about the formation of the world's first
gay rugby club I thought I just got to
join it and help in whatever way I can
at the Kim's Kristina's was the first
gay an inclusive replica lab founded in
1995 we currently have 250 active
members our club is made up of gay
bisexual and straight guys who are all
here to play and enjoy rugby together
there's many guys who self exclude
themselves from sport don't want to take
part at school who then went to get back
into a sport in their adult years and
need a social group in the society well
I always wanted to get into rugby and
was something a lot my family have
played but I wasn't too comfortable
joining one of the teams back of the
Newcastle
I wouldn't feel as comfortable joining a
club that doesn't label itself as
inclusive because you've got that little
niggle in the back of your head like
will they accept me for being gay will
they not whereas here they are very
accepting and I know that it won't be an
issue
it I thought I would just be here to
play the sport in an open and friendly
environment instead the club has become
another family being in an inclusive
environment of the Steelers is it's just
great
[Music]
from six people in November 1995 and a
small committee and not being able to
form a team through to having the
Steelers fielding up to six teams at any
given time it's a wonderful pleasure I
want and everybody in the club wants
people to enjoy playing rugby at
whatever level but at the same time be
able to say I'm gay and it doesn't
matter Society has changed so much over
the last 20 years and I just like to
think that we as a rugby club are
contributed in some small way to
you